[Musique]
non
on s'est dit vraiment cette année ça va
être une année blanche qu'on pourra pas
du tout tourné et c'est vraiment il ya
un mois
ce fameux fameux discours et que les
mesures ont été un peu assouplie
compagnie a pris le pari de partir de
donc on a redémarré un petit peu
la machine
du coup c'est une idée originale de
voile martin qui est un espèce de
fanatiques de piano qui fabrique plaint
de machines avec des pianos et qui un
jour jouer du piano sur les plages et
s'est dit ouah ça serait vraiment
chouette que le canot il a carrément
dans l'eau et il l'a fait
vous
[Musique]
nous avons décidé de les soutenir dans
cette période difficile donc en les
accueillant à richebourg c'est vrai que
ce n'était pas évident parce qu'il ya le
protocole sanitaire beaucoup de règles à
respecter mais si on ne soutient pas les
artistes
qu'est ce qu'ils vont devenir
[Musique]
il ya une espèce d'atmosphère file
électrique mais moi je suis très très
émue cette année plus que les autres
années
tout est d'avoir un public en face de
moi qui viens malgré cette situation